so we have four different molecules here
and what i want you to think about if
you had a pure sample of each which of
those pure samples would have the
highest boiling point second highest
third highest and fourth highest pause
this video and try to figure that out
all right
now to figure that out it really just
boils down to which of these has the
highest intermolecular forces when
they're in a liquid state because if you
have high intermolecular forces it would
take a lot of energy or a higher boiling
point to really overcome those
intermolecular forces and get to a gas
state so let's think about the
intermolecular forces that we have
studied so i will start with hydrogen
bonds hydrogen
bonds because you could really view
those those are the strongest of the
dipole-dipole interactions and they're
going to be stronger than your london
dispersion forces
we can see that diethyl ether won't form
hydrogen bonds we don't see any bonds
between hydrogen and an oxygen a
nitrogen or a fluorine ethanol has one
oxygen hydrogen bond methanol also has
one oxygen hydrogen bond
water has two oxygen hydrogen bonds so
if i had to rank the hydrogen bond
contribution to the intermolecular
forces i would put water as number one
because it can form the most hydrogen
bonds i would put methanol and ethanol
as a tie for a second and then i would
put diethyl ether last because it can't
form hydrogen bonds so just looking at
this i know that water is going to have
the highest boiling point diethyl ether
is going to have the lowest boiling
point but what about the difference
between methanol and ethanol
and we could think about other types of
dipole forces but not a lot that you
could intuit just by eyeballing them
they might actually have similar dipole
moments on a molecular basis but we can
think about london dispersion forces
i'll do this in a different color so
london
dispersion forces and if we're just
trying to actually i'll rank all of them
so london's dispersion forces are
proportional to the how polarizable a
molecule is which is proportional to how
large its electron cloud is what's
proportional to its molar mass and it's
clear that diethyl ether has the highest
molar mass followed by ethanol followed
by
methanol followed by water how did i
know that well you literally can take
atoms away from the diethyl ether to
get to an ethanol and you can literally
take atoms away from that to get to a
methanol and you can literally take
atoms away from that to get to a water
so we know that this is the order of
molar mass
and so london dispersion forces i
wouldn't make that change the ranking
between water or diethyl ether because
these are going to be a lot weaker than
those hydrogen bonds but they can be
useful for the tiebreaker between
ethanol and methanol and so my overall
ranking on boiling point the highest
boiling point i would put would be water
followed by
since ethanol won the tie breaker
followed by ethanol followed by
methanol and then the lowest boiling
point would be diethyl ether
and if we look at the actual data it's
consistent with what we just talked
about we can see very clearly that water
has the highest boiling point ethanol is
second methanol is third and diethyl
ether was fourth completely consistent
with our intuition
now what's also interesting here you
might have noticed is this thing called
vapor pressure and you might have also
noticed that vapor pressure seems to
trend the opposite way's boiling point
the things that have the high boiling
point have the low vapor pressure and
the things that have the low boiling
point have a high vapor pressure so what
are we talking about why about vapor
pressure and why do we see this
relationship
and i'm not going to go deep into vapor
pressure there'll be other videos on
that on khan academy but just to get you
a sense
imagine
a closed container here
and i put one of these one of a sample
of one of these molecules in a liquid
state and i'm going to just draw the
molecules clearly not drawn to scale as
these
little circles
and
the temperature matter so let's say that
this is at 20 degrees celsius now you
might notice at 20 degrees celsius it's
lower than the boiling point of all of
these characters so for the most part
they're going to be in a liquid state
but we know that not every one of these
molecules is moving with the exact same
kinetic energy the temperature you could
view as a measure of the average kinetic
energy of the molecules but they're all
bumping around into each other in
different positions with different
amounts of velocities and therefore
different kinetic energies and so every
now and then you're going to have a
molecule that has the right position and
the right kinetic energy to escape and
get into the vapor state into a gaseous
state
and so that's going to keep happening
but then the things that are in the
gaseous state every now and then they're
bumping into each other and they're
bumping into the sides of the container
and every now and then they might
approach the surface with the right
kinetic energy with the right position
so that they get recaptured by the
intermolecular forces and enter a liquid
state and so you can imagine this will
keep happening where things go from
liquid and then they go to vapor but
then when that vapor gets high enough
or when you could say the vapor pressure
gets high enough remember that pressure
is just from these the vapor molecules
bouncing around then you will get to
some form of an equilibrium and you
could imagine the things that have a
lower boiling point that means they have
lower intermolecular forces
more of the vapor is going to form and
so you're going to have a higher vapor
pressure before you get to equilibrium
on the other hand things with high
intermolecular forces fewer of those
molecules are going to break away and so
you're going to have a lower vapor
pressure when you get to that
equilibrium and you can see that very
clearly here
so i will leave you there we got a
little bit of practice seeing everything
we've seen so far and we got we learned
a little bit about vapor pressure and
how that relates to intermolecular
forces and boiling point